good morning believe nation today's
message is just do it over to you art
Williams I found two things out about
smart people I think it's almost
impossible for a smart person to win in
business in America today because I find
smart people spend their whole lifetime
figuring things out
they always time to figure out an easier
way in a quicker way and another thing I
found out about smart people they just
don't get around to doing nothing they
see somebody like art Williams everybody
says well he can't do it that's somebody
like that can't do it but he does it see
folks I want you to know almost
everybody in America almost does enough
to win they almost get there they almost
over the hump they almost have it going
they almost in everything they do almost
as a way of life to almost everybody in
America but the winners do it what do
they do they do whatever it takes to get
the job done they do it and do it and do
it and do it and do it until the job
gets done and then they talk about how
great it is to be somebody they're proud
of we need leaders in America who can do
it if you want to become somebody do it
if you want to go in business for
yourself do it if you want to become
financially independent do it I hear too
much talk in these United States
everybody can talk a good game we need
people in America who can do it I go all
over this country with Al weaves and I
have people say aren't you you count on
me wonderful just do it hard I can't eat
my light last stop I'm gonna win now
SuperDuper just do it all right if I
could just have one good month and get
the ball going I know I could make it
big super just do it hard if I could
just pay off this debt I could really go
great just do it
hard if I could just sell my house do it
but how's they selling do it anyway are
I'm not making any money what can I do
you just do it let's do what art you do
it and do it and do it all right I can't
ever win this contest
SuperDuper just do it I'm over the hump
now watch my smoke greens just do it
hard I want to make it so bad I can
taste it what I do you just do it all
right I'm a vice president now can I
quit doing it no my heart I don't know
if I keep on keeping on I'm really hurt
what I do you just do it do what art you
do it and do it and do it all right all
my life I want to be somebody important
well what do it then all right I'm gonna
save money so I don't have to go through
this again gray hey just do it all right
I don't feel like I've had enough
training what I do you just do it
how are my manners you don't give me no
help what I do you just do it all right
you don't understand I was mr.
everything in my former company you
don't mean I I have to start off down at
the bottom and do it do you
yep you really got to do it
Bart what's the primary difference
between winners and losers the winner
the winners do it they do it and do it
and do it and do it until the job gets
done and then they talk about how great
it is to finally achieve something you
need and how glad they are that they
didn't quit like everybody else and how
wonderful it is to finally be somebody
they're proud of and make a difference
with their life thank you so that was so
legendary I'm just gonna leave it as it
is and just get up to the question of
the day is what is holding you back from
just doing it leaving the comments below
I'm super curious to find out I'm gonna
join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick shout out to Alexander
clues from start up strong calm thank
you so much for picking up a cup of my
book really means a lot to me those are
you watching with a chance at a future
shout out in a video make sure to pick
up a copy of the book and email in your
seats to keep track thank you guys so
much for watching we continue to believe
or whatever your one word is and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of its best